[Music]
we all love cartoons but sometimes they
keep us on the edge of our seats with
their ongoing mysteries what's the
Krabby Patty secret formula what do the
loud house parents look like how much is
Dexter's laboratories electricity bill
make sure you watch this video until the
end to know the answer to all your
questions if you're new here make sure
to like this video and subscribe to
never miss a video again today we're
discussing ten cartoon secrets finally
revealed krabby patty formula let's
start with the secret that we've been
dying to have the answer for quite a lot
of seasons of Spongebob Squarepants what
actually is the secret krabby patty
formula that makes these burgers so
delicious it's something Plankton's
can't wait to find out what we believe
the secret has actually been cracked
some time ago at least that's what the
fans think of course we've all seen the
secret formula for Krabby Patties that's
actually just gibberish tax with added
measurements another episode also showed
spongebob actually preparing the burger
from scratch while this was a pretty
decent krabby patty formula reveal it's
still not the real thing and SpongeBob
SquarePants fans are dying to find out
the real formula just as much as
plankton this secret recipe which was
supposedly published on nick.com shows
off a bunch of different ingredients
including crab meat this caused a huge
concern with Twitter users so much so
that Nickelodeon had to step in and
declare that mr. crab was definitely not
a cannibal the mystery remains
however this reddit user shared an
interesting theory that Krabby Patty's
secret formula is actually nothing the
user claims that having a secret formula
is just a ruse to keep plankton occupied
and stop him from opening his own
business while the show might never
fully reveal the secret formula fans
have so many theories we bet at least
one of them is true Tom and Jerry's
mammy two-shoes if you're a 90s kid
you've probably grown up watching Sunday
morning cartoons and one of them
included Tom and Terry The Adventures of
the popular cat and mouse have been a
part of a lot of people's childhoods
but there's one mystery we never even
remember being revealed
do you remember mammy two-shoes she's a
heavyset african-american woman that
frequently appears in the episodes to
boss the two characters around
we usually only see her from the waist
down but you know it's mammy two-shoes
from her sleeveless dress white apron
yellow socks and red slippers her
character was inspired by Hattie
McDaniel who played mammy and Gone with
the Wind we've always wondered what
mammy two-shoes actually looked like and
we finally managed to find a face reveal
here's what mammy looks like in the 48th
Tom and Jerry episode we finally see
Mami's actual face but you have to be
fast if you want to catch it when mammy
leaves for her Saturday night bridge
club Tom decides to throw a cat party
Jerry of course calls mammy and tells
her what happened she rushes back home
and as you can see her running you can
catch a glimpse of what her face looks
like it's the only episode that ever
features Mami's face but if you don't
pause it at the right time you're going
to miss it
wizard Kelly from proud family proud
family is a Disney cartoon that follows
the life of penny proud and her family
the show is hilarious and it has a
character that sparked quite a lot of
mystery over the years wizard Kelly is a
retired basketball player that
frequently appears on proud family he's
incredibly arrogant and cocky and he has
an absolutely terrible memory
you probably remember him from never
knowing the characters actual names he
was also the character that never showed
the front of his face much like a lot of
other characters will show you today
wizard Kelly also went viral after a few
people spotted the similarity with a
White House official standing in the
background of one of Obama's speeches
there's no real explanation why Disney
decided to only show him from the neck
down but we did manage to find what
wizard Kelley actually looks like you
can actually catch him in the proud
family movie but you have to pay close
attention it happens in this scene where
they were being swept away by peanut
butter and just for us lit second you
can see wizard Kelley falling while he's
running away while he's falling he
finally reveals his face much to the
surprise of the proud family fans what
do you think of his face have you
imagined him looking like this comic
book guy's name here's one show that is
so iconic
everyone knows its theme songs but do
you know it had a character whose secret
wasn't really revealed until seventeen
seasons later The Simpsons super fans
probably know this but if you don't know
everything about the show this might
come as a huge surprise
remember the comic book guy that
frequently appears on the show he's the
sarcastic
owner of the comic book store in
Springfield and he's mostly known for
his almost dramatic passion for comic
books the fans of the show had to accept
that his name was just the comic book
guy for quite a lot of years before the
reveal finally came around in season 17
the name reveal happens in the episode
called Homer and Ned's Hail Mary pass
where the comic book guy finally admits
to Ned that his name is actually Jeff
Albertson the episode aired during the
Super Bowl show and the reveal sent
shockwaves throughout the show's fan
base fans were so invested in finding
out the real name of the guy they
actually got upset his name is something
as generic as Jeff Albertson it turns
out that the creators of the show did
this on purpose just to make the viewers
angry does the comic book guy look like
Jeff to you some super fans are in such
denial
they still refer to him by his nickname
rather than his actual name Powerpuff
Girls Miz cerebellum Cartoon Network
loves to hide faces from random adult
characters of their shows and MS
cerebellum from the Powerpuff Girls was
one of them the show first aired in 1998
and this headless character with stylish
outfits appeared in many episodes you
could usually find her alongside the
mayor as she was his deputy and so
called the brains of the operation quite
ironic considering that we never got to
see her actual head isn't it her read
long curly hair often covers a lot of
her face but she's known for her red
outfit and fashionable high-heeled shoes
Sara's role is to be the voice of reason
for the mayor as well as the girls but
she's also pretty skilled at
hand-to-hand combat her character was
pretty important and we're honestly
surprised her face was only shown in a
single scene it was revealed on the 10th
anniversary TV special called the
Powerpuff Girls rule yes the Powerpuff
Girls fans had to wait 10 years to
finally see Miss cerebellums face
luckily you won't have to wait that long
here it is it was only shown for a split
second and it could be easily ignored
but we managed to catch a glimpse of it
is this what you imagined the sweet
Valon to look like a wonder she gets
called sweet cheeks
cow and chickens parents no one knows
why cartoons love to hide the faces of
adult characters the cow and chicken is
another show where we never really see
what the parents look like out of all
cartoons out there this is the one where
people should actually see who the
parents are of these questionably
biological siblings it's hard to believe
cow and chicken are even siblings in the
first place and the cherry on top to
this strange show is of course the red
guy who is on a completely different
level of bizarre well if you're really
wondering what cow and chickens parents
actually look like you'd better hold on
to your seats because we're about to
show you and though they don't have
human bodies and animal heads they're
actually human all together in an
episode called cow and chicken reclining
you can see chicken throwing things out
of the closet one of the things he pulls
out is cows science project which is the
upper bodies of his parents while it
hasn't been confirmed that these are
actually cow and chickens parents you
can easily see that their clothing
matches the clothes of the actual
characters out of all face reveals this
has to be our absolute favorite Kenny
from South Park and who can forget about
South Park one of the best adult
cartoons there is South Park draws in a
huge audience that tunes into watch
every single episode it's known for
having absolutely no filter and the show
loves to use humour to portray the
world's social issues and other
controversial topics one of the biggest
mysteries of South Park is Kenny one of
the main characters who is always
wearing a hoodie to hide his face and
muffle his voice there are actually
several episodes where Kenny partially
reveals his face without the hoodie but
there's one special scene that bully
reveals Kenny's face hair and his
speaking voice
in 1999 the South Park creators released
South Park bigger Longer & uncut a
popular movie based on the series at the
end of the movie Kenny might have a
tragic ending but the creators have
cleverly decided to turn it into a nice
sonic scene like
lately revealing his face and his voice
the fandom loved it and if you haven't
seen it yet it's definitely a movie to
watch and unlike many other face reveals
were showing you today this is the only
one where you don't have to pause the
movie at the perfect time to get a
glimpse of this wonderful face reveal we
have to say Kenny is quite handsome
Dexter's Laboratory electric bill here's
an interesting reveal for you have you
ever seen the popular Cartoon Network
show called Dexter's Laboratory in a
summary a boy called Dexter runs a
science lab in the basement of his
parents house he gets frequently annoyed
with a sister DeeDee who just loves to
test out everything there is in his
laboratory and that often leads to no
good
once you start getting into the cartoon
you'll notice that Dexter does spend a
lot of time in his laboratory and many
fans have been asking the same question
what is Dexter's electricity bill and
how come his parents don't know he's
running a full laboratory underneath the
house well we finally managed to find
the answers for this one and it's not
just called cartoon logic although we
have to admit that cartoon logic is
definitely flawed in Dexter's Laboratory
Dexter has frequently been shown as
being strapped for cash and having to
sell lots of stuff to NASA and other
companies many fans suspect he's simply
also stealing power from someone else in
an episode called rip paranoid an
electrician comes to repair a fuse and
Dexter uses him to fix his lab
electricals when the final bill is
issued it shows up as a whopping forty
thousand dollars which is probably the
amount Dexter spends on his electricity
bill here's another question for you how
on earth is he able to afford this
Eddie's brother from Edie Edie and Eddie
and Eddie and Eddie is a show every 90s
kid enjoyed watching
do you remember everyone on the show
Eddie's brother is one of those
characters that gets frequently
mentioned even though he's never
actually seen on the show yes you
probably didn't even know that Eddie
even had a brother if you didn't pay
close attention black sands of Edie and
and Eddie have definitely heard of
Eddie's brother and all his adventures
we never see him because he moved out
but Eddie treats him like a role model
according to Eddie his brother's smart
cool and multi-talented he has a couple
of secrets and unfortunately one of them
will probably remain a mystery forever
the thing is we don't really
no Eddie's brothers full name even
though they showed us his room and we
were told of his stories Eddie's brother
remains a mystery however his face
finally gets revealed in ed Edd n Eddy's
Big Picture Show movie that first aired
in 2009 ten years after the first ed ed
and Eddy episode and here he is looking
just as cool as Eddie has described him
you can definitely tell that the two of
them are brothers and it is cute the way
Eddie admires his older brother although
the show has ended we do have one
question we'd love to have an answer to
does anyone know Eddie's brother's
actual name the loud house parents we've
said it before but we actually think we
are the biggest loud house fans there
are the show is our favorite you can
find a dozen of loud house videos on our
channel where we showcase what the
characters would look like reimagined in
alternate cartoon universes but there
are two characters we always leave out
and there's a good reason behind it
we've never seen their faces just like
typical cartoon parents mommy and daddy
loud only ever show the bottom half of
their bodies the two are very loving
toward their children and act as caring
parents who are also Stern when they
need to be there were a few glimpses of
what their faces might actually look
like throughout the season but we've
never seen them complete on the loud
house Christmas special we finally got
to see what the parents look like
they're spotted after the family brings
Christmas family spirit to their
neighbor it's also the first time we see
the entire loud family and their friends
together in a single tank we bet there
was a fan that wished they could see
what Rita and Lynne loud senior look
like and Nickelodeon actually delivered
it during the Christmas special that
really did make all of our Christmases
so much more special and we absolutely
adore their faces that's it for
revealing cartoon secrets for more
videos like this one make sure to watch
10 cartoons that look different in other
countries see you next time
[Music]